here comes the first sign all the  divorce talk could be over Ben and Jen  took the whole family to church on  Sunday  the second sign of reconciliation Ben  and Jenner together qalaat and it's not  just co-parenting last Tuesday they were  snapped hitting their polling station  together in Brentwood on Election Day  officially nothing has changed then  continues to live on their property no  divorce papers have been filed and Ben  is committed to daddy duty how do you  make all that work I mean you guys got a  lot going on Medora bus window retired  guys been told Graham Norton his  four-year-old son recently had an  inadvertent royal playdate during a  visit to London I was the last person in  there for sure to realize that the the  Royal George and the those kids were in  there playing and my son was in there  playing so now I can tell him like you  got a cold from the king of England